finally tonight notable quotables you
want an emergency we have an emergency
some really bad things happened to Otto
he tells me that he didn't know about it
and I will take him at his word it's
strong new reaction coming in from the
parents of otto warmbier calling out kim
jong on over their son's death this is
nonsense you guys know it I know it
talking is definitely better than
fighting theories are not for action
it's cool when you call Donald Trump a
cheat in your opening testimony what
would you call yourself fool you're a
pathological liar
I'm not calling him a bunny baller but
he's a little unbalanced president
Donald Trump has more stories than Harry
Potter the relationship was very warm
and when we walked away it was a very
friendly walk I'll let the ankle-biters
just bite all right
luckily a really nice lady came in and
gave me some pull-ups politics stops at
the water county embattled singer R
Kelly is released from custody the ref
made a bad call the opposition party is
flailing and failing just because I'm
not running I'm not gonna keep you know
my mouth shut